merci d'être avec nous ce matin Agnès
canaillé d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes élu de la
Seine-Maritime à parenté au groupe les
républicains vous êtes l'une du
rapporteurs de ce texte sur
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques 2024 l'examen débuté hier
on va évidemment parler dans quelques
instants mais d'abord la réforme des
retraites évidemment qui est toujours
dans l'actualité ça y est le texte a été
présenté en Conseil des ministres il
arrivera en commission dès lundi à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que c'est
un texte que vous voterez en l'état bah
écoutez oui puisque le Sénat a toujours
voté de manière constante les
propositions qui sont en ce texte de loi
à savoir les 64 ans et les 43 années de
cotisation donc nous sommes cohérents
nous sommes dans la lignée donc c'est
dans votre sans problème en tout cas la
majorité sénatoriale votera même si nous
aurons effectivement sûrement des
amendements d'amélioration de ce
dispositif extrêmement technique et
complexe mais qui pourra quelques et on
l'a vu encore avec l'actualité
difficulté de bord qu'il faudra
certainement corriger notamment pourquoi
parce qu'on entend des sénateurs les
républicains s'inquiéter notamment sur
le fait que certains Français vont
devoir cotiser 44 ans est-ce que ça ça
fait partie des choses que vous allez
chercher à modifier dans le texte oui
tout à fait je pense que ça ça fait des
parties des dispositions pour qu'il y
ait une plus grande égalité notamment
sur les carrières longues il y a aussi
toute la question de la pénibilité sans
remettre en question tous les critères
mais au moins mieux accompagner les
carrières et les fans carrière je pense
qu'il y a pas mal de propositions à
faire aussi sur le travail des seniors
notamment dans la transmission aussi
parce que ils sont aussi des atouts pour
les entreprises et il y a certainement
moyen aussi de et bien d'atténuer les
dernières années notamment sur des
postes un peu difficiles avec aussi des
mesures coercitives parce que beaucoup
disent l'index senior qui a dans le
texte ça suffit pas hier soir Olivier
Véran a dit qu'il était ouvert sur ce
sujet à des modifications parlementaires
il faut des mesures plus coercitives oui
je pense qu'il faut aussi inciter
fortement les entreprises à maintenir
les seniors dans les entreprises et à
les utiliser de manière positive en leur
confiant des responsabilités notamment
de transmission aux plus jeunes je pense
qu'ils ont un rôle majeur à mener dans
ce domaine là et puis on l'a vu il y a
cette polémique cette incendie allumée
par Franck Riester sur notre antenne qui
dit que les femmes seraient un peu
pénalisées par cette réforme hier aux
questions d'actualité Elisabeth borne a
dénoncé un faux procès nous protégeons
les femmes qui ont une carrière
incomplète et hacher les femmes qui ont
commencé à travailler tôt qui ont des
petites pensions vous êtes convaincus
par ça ben écoutez c'est un quoique de
communication alors c'est vrai que à la
fois les femmes sur les montants des
pensions et notamment des minimum seront
en profiteront largement puisque c'est
elle qui ont les carrières les plus
hachées et qui ont le moins de de
cotisations totales leur permettant
d'avoir une retraite planée entière
néanmoins on voit bien que l'allongement
du délai de cotisation et du report de
la retraite surtout ne profitera pas aux
femmes qui ont une carrière et en même
temps qui ont eu quelques maternités
donc voilà donc c'est est-ce que c'est
une réforme Ant comme on l'entend du
côté de la gauche
non je pense pas que c'est une réforme
antifam il y a des effets de bord sur
les femmes qui ont effectivement un
allongement qui pèsera plus pour elle
que pour les hommes mais globalement les
femmes qui ont des carrières hachées
elles profiteront de du minimum de
retraite donc on s'est un équilibre à
trouver peut-être qu'il y aura des
mesures de perfectionnement à introduire
et ça le Sénat fera son job
en mars en attendant le texte examinant
le scénar examine en ce moment même un
texte sur l'organisation des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024 le
l'examen pardon a débuté hier on vous en
êtes l'une des rapporteurs on voit ce
qui s'est passé hier en séance avec si
Flandin
[Musique]
bonjour madame monsieur
bien qui porte sur les JO 2024 mais on a
surtout parlée sécurité hier sur ce
point le gouvernement et le Sénat sont
d'accord il faut muscler le jeu en
matière de sécurité il faut dire que les
chiffres donnent un peu le vertige 15000
athlètes sont attendus pour les jeux 4
milliards de téléspectateurs à travers
le monde 800 000 personnes à acheminer
chaque jour en France 50000 forces de
sécurité publique et privées seront
déployés alors tout ça demande un peu
d'organisation et d'anticipation c'est
tout l'objet du texte présenté hier par
le gouvernement Intex trop axé sur la
sécurité pour les communistes écoutées
nous ne pouvons regretter et dénoncer un
texte hautement sécuritaire qui porte
mal son nom il est bien dommage que ce
texte nous parle moins de sport que de
sécurité ce projet de loi j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire est un cheval de
Troie tant les dispositions à
tentatoires aux libertés et droits
fondamentaux qu'ils comporte seront
susceptibles d'être pérennes et c'est
déjà le cas pour 11 d'entre elles et si
pendant les séances et là notamment été
question d'une mesure en particulier oui
de l'introduction de caméra intelligente
dans le dispositif de sécurité ce sont
des caméras qui permettent de détecter
des mouvements de foule suspects
concrètement des algorithmes seront
utilisés pour repérer des comportements
jugés anormaux ces comportements seront
automatiquement signalés aux forces de
l'ordre qui décideront s'il faut ou pas
intervenir il s'agit pour l'instant
d'une expérimentation mais une
expérimentation qui pourra tout de même
être utilisée jusqu'en juin 2025 soit
après les JO Gérald Darmanin a expliqué
le fonctionnement de ses caméras à
écouter le
elle pourra regarder quelle est
l'événement que nous souhaitons
retrouver où la situation que ce sont
retrouvées le comportement que ce sont
retrouvés à rassemblement extrêmement
intempestif
casse d'abribus un sac posé par terre et
ne visera pas à rechercher monsieur
dessus monsieur Darmanin ou monsieur
Durin ces caméras de sécurité
intelligentes la majorité sénatoriale et
pour à condition que leur utilisation
soit encadrée le Sénat soumet le
dispositif à des mesures de contrôle
humain à la formation de des personnes
habilités à accéder au signalement ou
encore à l'accompagnement et au contrôle
de la CNIL des garanties loin d'être
suffisante pour les écologistes écoutez
ne vous faites pas d'illusions sur les
garde-fous qui ont été introduits dans
cette loi l'expérimentation qui est
proposée ici une offre donc aucune
garantie sur les droits et liberté des
personnes pour plusieurs raisons mais
d'abord parce que ces algorithmes de son
ni contrôlables ni transparents
contre l'utilisation de ces caméras elle
présente des risques pour nos libertés
individuelles selon vous effectivement
c'est un dispositif qui est innovant et
c'est une innovation qui est majeure
relever comme tel partout mais
nécessaire vous l'avez dit dans le cadre
de cette sécurisation de jeux olympiques
qui sont un événement d'ampleur inédite
notamment avec la cérémonie d'ouverture
en plein air qui est du jamais vu donc
il faut pour ce type d'événement avoir
des outils d'autant que le risque
terrorisme est encore extrêmement
présent sur notre territoire il faut pas
se le cacher donc dès lors que l'on met
en place des outils de vidéoprotection
et a fortiori intelligente donc couplé à
des algorithmes il y a des traitements
de données personnelles donc il atteinte
à des libertés individuelles le tout est
trouvé le juste équilibre et de mettre
dans la balance entre
opérationnalisbilité sécurité nécessaire
et garantie des droits et des libertés
suffisamment de cliquer pour assurer que
que ça ne penche pas dans le mauvais
sens c'est ce qu'a fait d'une part le
gouvernement en réécrivant le texte
après le passage devant le Conseil
d'État et la CNIL est-ce qu'on a fait au
Sénat en renforçant encore ses garanties
vous l'avez cité notamment sous le
contrôle humain avec le contrôle
permanent de la CNIL et avec des
obligations de formation donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il y a à l'enjeu nous
sommes arrivés à un système
proportionnel donc c'est pourquoi nous
avons voté ce texte il n'y aura pas de
reconnaissance faciale utilisée vous le
regrettez vous auriez souhaité que on
utilise la reconnaissance faciale à
l'occasion de ces Jeux Olympiques ça
aurait pu être un outil supplémentaire
encore ça veut pas dire que forcément
utiliser mais un outil supplémentaire
parce que déjà c'est dans 18 mois les
Jeux Olympiques on avait parlé
effectivement de d'un événement d'une
ampleur qui va susciter un nombre de
forces de l'ordre considérable on sait
déjà qu'il va y avoir un problème de
recrutement des agents des forces de
sécurité privée qui pour les quasiment
encore aujourd'hui 20 personne ça va
être une organisation extrêmement
ciselée extrêmement complexe à mettre en
place donc à un moment donné il faut des
outils cependant on voit bien que le
débat n'est pas mûr on voit bien que à
apporter cette outil qui là est encore
plus intrusif la reconnaissance faciale
par la voix d'amendement dans un texte
sur les JO et pour lequel le
gouvernement n'est pas d'accord c'est
dit que c'était pas le moment c'était
pas ce risque d'attentat que vous
pointez est-ce que ça n'aurait pas été
un outil nécessaire mais mais un vrai
risque effectivement alors après
derrière il y a un deuxième sujet c'est
est-ce que cette opérationnel est-ce
qu'on est en capacité aujourd'hui de
mettre en place cette reconnaissance
biométrique telle que l'avait présenté
notre collègue marquise de Brest
extrêmement cerné pour les JO pour
quelle sur des autorisations de 48
heures sur des caméras embarquées
propres dans des camions enfin etc etc
donc c'était très très ciblé mais on a
bien senti que l'opinion publique
n'était pas prête ni la majorité de
natale ce texte prévoit aussi la
possibilité de recourir à des scanners
corporels donc entre quand j'arrive au
stade et si je refuse de me soumettre au
scanner qu'est ce qui se passe et bien
vous serez l'objet d'une palpation comme
habituellement donc ça c'est il y a le
choix c'est pas une obligation
certains considèrent que le scanner est
moins intrusif parce qu'on ne vous tous
déjà dans les aéroports là c'est étendu
effectivement aux enceintes sportives
voilà ça existe dans les aéroports donc
là il y a forcément une information
obligatoire en la rajouter et il y aura
une seule solution alternative c'est la
palpation corporelle il y a des
inquiétudes des de la part de certains
qui disent que ce texte qui est fait
pour les JO et face à l'ampleur
évidemment du dispositif aux JO ne
contiennent des dispositifs qui vont
devenir pérenne et qui donc vont porter
atteinte liberté publique de manière
durable qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça
ah oui alors c'est vrai que il y a un
intitulé du texte qui est sobre aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques sauf que
quand on regarde sur les 19 articles il
y en a celui qui concerne spécifiquement
les Jeux Olympiques le reste est des
mises en conformité de dispositifs ou
alors comme la vidéoprotection
intelligente une expérimentation dans le
JO les JO sont un accélérateur oui mais
je vois bien on le voit bien par exemple
l'histoire de la possibilité pour le
secos quels sont de coordination
opérationnelles en matière de sécurité
dans les transports d'élargir les
visionnages dans le respect des
garanties constitutionnelles des images
qui sont rendues par les caméras de la
RATP et la SNCF ça a manqué au moment
des épisodes du Stade de France donc il
y aura d'autres grandes compétitions on
aura les Mondiaux cyclisme en 2027 donc
il y a un moment donné on en aura encore
besoin de cette finale cette fiasco de
l'organisation de la finale de la Ligue
des Champions c'est ce que ce texte il
répond à ça est-ce qu'avec ce texte un
tel fiasco nous pourrait pour une plus
reproduire écouter malheureusement je
pense que les fiasco il y en aura
toujours est-ce que c'est aussi une
question d'organisation et de
coordination
et de la manière dont c'était anticipé
ces grandes manifestations et on sait
qu'on va en avoir encore de nombreuses
elles sont pas simplement sportives
elles peuvent être aussi culturelles on
va avoir des des commémorations du
débarquement de 80e anniversaire de
débarquement Normandie il y a plein
d'événements bref
des dispositions ont été introduites
notamment plus grande incrimination
quand on s'introduit frauduleusement
dans un stade ou qu'on s'entroduit sur
une aire de jeux et puis l'obligation de
mettre en place des billets à falsifiés
on avait vu que c'était un des gros
enjeux donc ce sont des dispositions
vous assurez que elle elle toute seule
elles assureront la sécurisation de
toutes les manifestations sportives ça
je pense que nous en sommes loin selon
vous on est prêt la France est prête
aujourd'hui accueillir les JO ou pas
alors d'aujourd'hui nous mais nous il y
a des affaires encore 548 jours donc il
y a encore beaucoup de choses à faire il
y a un enjeu de taille je sais que
effectivement tous les acteurs sont
mobilisés beaucoup que ce soit le Kojo
que ce soit le dijab le dégâts
ministériel aux Jeux Olympiques
évidemment le gouvernement est beaucoup
de ministères sont sensibilisés à ce
sujet là qui va au fur et à mesure qu'on
va se rapprocher de venir un sujet
premier pour l'ensemble des actions donc
il y a beaucoup de réunions mais c'est
un enjeu de taille il faudra être au
rendez-vous il y a une vraie pression
nous on suivra de près pour être sûr que
tout sera prêt pour l'ouverture en
juillet 2024 hier soir Gérald Darmanin
dit qu'il ne pouvait pas dire s'il sera
nécessaire ou non de recourir à l'armée
pour sécurité les Jeux Olympiques
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez écoutez
effectivement c'est un peu tôt mais il
faut le prévoir mais on peut pas le
prévoir d'entrée de jeu c'est un moyen
supplémentaire et qui sera subsidiaire
c'est-à-dire que si on n'a pas les
forces de l'ordre public suffisante et
privées en nombre aussi suffisant alors
il y aura toujours le recours à l'armée
mais on peut pas dire aujourd'hui alors
qu'on est encore à plus de du mois on
recourera l'armée il y a cette
possibilité là je pense qu'il faudrait
pouvoir s'en passer parce qu'il y aura
et c'est un débat que vous aurez la
sécurisation de tous les autres
événements sur le territoire c'est à
dire que il y a des inquiétudes fortes
de peur et on a eu ces déballages hier
que les JO rentre impossible les autres
festivals les autres manifestations
notamment culturelles donc il y a les JO
mais il y a aussi le reste et il faudra
trouver le geste qui est donc dire
aujourd'hui effectivement qu'on
réquisonnera l'armée c'est un peu tôt
mais on sait que c'est une possibilité
est-ce que je joue sur cette question
des festivals il y a eu un manque
d'anticipation de la part du
gouvernement c'est ça date pas de
quelques mois cette désignation de la
France pour accueillir les Jeux
olympiques est-ce que quelque part le
gouvernement a trop tardé à réagir sur
cette question de la culture et des
festivals
oui je pense que la circulaire qui vient
d'être
transmise au préfet effectivement un peu
encore allumé le feu sur ce sujet là
parce qu'il y a une vraie inquiétude de
pouvoir organiser parce qu'on sent bien
que il va me focalisation de l'ensemble
des forces de l'ordre sur les Jeux
Olympiques on voit que c'est chaque
prédé qui décidera bon reste à savoir
comment ça se fera dans le dialogue avec
les collectivités locales
il y aura des risques d'inégalités mais
déjà toute façon les Jeux olympiques
sont pas sur les territoires il y a 63
collectivités hautes et le territoire
compadio donc les territoires n'ont pas
de Gio il y aura moins de danger moins
de sécurisation alors voilà est-ce que
pour eux ça sera pas plus simple
j'ai vu une autre question ou pas oui
sur les tests génétiques le texte
prévoit effectivement de la possibilité
de recourir à des tests génétiques sur
les sportifs en matière de lutte contre
le dopage on est en retard en la matière
oui la France est en retard et la France
a tardé à se mettre en conformité avec
le code mondial antidopage c'est une
demande de longue haleine de l'Etat qui
est instance de contrôle et l'Agence
française de lutte contre le dopage on a
signé les engagements internationaux en
2007 et on s'était toujours pas mis en
conformité donc nous on a considéré au
départ c'était prévu uniquement pour les
Jeux Olympiques nous avons considéré au
Sénat que dès lors c'est une mise en
conformité avec des engagements
internationaux fallait que ce soit
pérenne tout ça qu'on a réécrit
l'article 4 qui introduit les tests
génétiques avec de nombreuses garanties
parce que là aussi il y a des enjeux
d'atteinte aux libertés individuelles
notamment l'impossibilité d'identifier
de pas connaître le patrimoine génétique
total et puis l'information nécessaire
et obligatoire de l'athlète l'Océanis
positif qui sera utilisé pour tous les
sportif pour toutes les compétitions
sportives à partir de maintenant oui
écoutez les athlètes français sont déjà
testés à l'étranger alors on voit pas
pourquoi ils peuvent pas être testés en
France
concernant l'actualité concernant ces
Jeux Olympiques hier vous le dit Merzel
inscrit le président ukrainien a demandé
à Emmanuel Macron de ne pas accueillir
d'athlètes russes pendant les JO 2024
qu'en pensez-vous bah écoutez on connaît
la situation de l'Ukraine dramatique
aujourd'hui et on si le président de la
République ukrainien est remarquable
dans dans sa maîtrise et dans son
commandement on voit aussi qu'il a une
forte communication qu'il fait pression
sur tous les états je pense que par
contre c'est pas une décision qui
dépendra du président de la République
mais bien du CIO donc je pense pas que
ce soit manuel Macron qui soit à la
manœuvre pour décider si les athlètes
russes participeront pas Emmanuel Macron
qui a dit au moment de la coupe du monde
de foot qu'il fallait pas politiser le
sport il peut prendre position là dessus
après avoir dit ça écoutez il peut
toujours prendre position mais c'est pas
lui qui a les mains à la main sur la
décision là c'est bon
et des JO 2024 on va parler de
l'actualité dans votre département on va
essayer de se connecter à atterrir
habillé du côté de Rouen dans quelques
instants mais d'abord on va parler d'une
actualité qui concerne également la
Seine-Maritime ça concerne tout le
territoire mais notamment le vote c'est
la décision annoncée par Marc fenault de
ne plus recourir au néonicotinoïdes ces
pesticides coupures d'abeille dit tueurs
d'abeilles qu'on utilisait qu'utiliser
notamment les producteurs de betteraves
on sait que c'est un sujet important
dans votre département est-ce que Marc
féno a eu raison de prendre cette
décision bah écoutez il avait pas
beaucoup de choix parce que cette
décision elle lui est imposée par la
Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
donc la France faisant partie de
l'Europe il normal qu'il se mette en
conformité avec des décisions de justice
il y avait déjà des dérogations
oui il y avait déjà des dérogations mais
si c'est pour être sanctionné et être
condamné lourdement et on sait que toute
on avait l'épée de Damoclès au dessus de
la tête maintenant c'est vrai que c'est
un enjeu fort pour les betteraviers moi
je le connais je le connais
particulièrement cette question en
Seine-Maritime qui est un gros
producteur de betteraves et ça fait
partie de l'économie de la
polyculturelle vache de nos fermes
normandes et déjà que l'élevage
aujourd'hui souffre du Laos du cou de
l'énergie le lin c'est très sujet au
changement climatique bon maintenant la
betterave qui vient aussi perdre sa
rentabilité donc c'est compliqué il
faudra que le gouvernement trouve des
solutions d'abord qu'il y ait de plus en
plus de recherches à la matière parce
qu'il faut trouver des solutions
alternatives et on voit que ça évolue
très lentement et puis faudra trouver
aussi des modalités d'indemnisation
parce que ça va mettre en péril toute
une filière et pas simplement
agricole mais aussi toute la filière du
sucre il y a des sucreries madame
sucreries de Fontaine-le-Dun derrière
c'est aussi le transport par des camions
bref il y a tout un écosystème autour du
sucre et ces dernières éléments c'est
pour faire importer du sucre venu
du Sud qui lui est cultivé avec des
néonicotinoïdes je vois pas très bien ce
qu'on aura gagné vous dites l'inquiétude
évidemment pour les producteurs de
betteraves marques fait non a promis de
les soutenir est-ce que vous êtes
inquiète sur le soutien du gouvernement
ou est-ce que vous avez tout confiance
en moi
écoutez j'aurais plutôt conscience en
Marsault qui connaît bien ces sujets
maintenant il faut voir il faut voir à
quelle hauteur et il faut voir si cette
indemnisation qui peut pas être une
solution pérenne comment aussi des
solutions vont être trouvées pour aider
les agriculteurs à continuer à produire
de la betterave sans atteinte par des
des virus qui viendraient abîmer la
betterave on a du mal à pour être tout à
fait franche et pour aller du côté droit
du coup je vais je vais vous parler de
ce dont il comptait vous parler c'est ce
projet de terminale méthanier flottant
il y a eu des référés qui ont été
déposés par les écologistes et qui ont
été rejetées les écologistes qui disent
évidemment qu'ils vont maintenir le
combat qu'est-ce qui se passe du côté de
ce terminal métallier flottant et est-ce
que pour vous ce projet est toujours
indispensable oui tout à fait
vous avez voté favorablement je m'étais
exprimé au moment de votre du texte de
loi sur le pouvoir d'achat donc qui a
instauré des dérogations pour la mise en
place du terminal mécanique flottant au
Havre on en a besoin parce que la guerre
en Ukraine a rebattu les cartes en ce
qui m'a concerne effectivement la
fourniture de gaz et notamment avec la
faute de gaz russe donc il faut trouver
des solutions alternatives on a un
problème comment avoir suffisamment de
gaz pour l'hiver prochain donc il faut
trouver des solutions d'autant que les
quatre stations de méthanisation sont
aujourd'hui pleine donc il faut trouver
d'autres solutions alternatives c'est le
terminal flottant il est flottant il est
donc réversible c'est pas définitif et
d'une part d'autre part c'est vrai qu'il
faut aller vite parce que c'est l'hiver
prochain les délais sont contraints d'où
la nécessité de réduire un certain
nombre de procédures on est assez fort
en France pour alourdir les procédures
et mettre énormément de temps pour
sortir des projets on le voit sur les
parcs éoliens au sort on le voit sur les
lignes nouvelles de train etc etc on a
on s'est assuré que toute les contrôles
en matière de sécurité étaient assurées
et sur la sécurité on a cette vraie
culture du risque industriel au Havre
dans cette zone industrielle fortement
cbzo on s'est assuré ce sur quoi c'est
on a raccourci les délais pour
travailler en temps masqué et on a
raccourci les délais sur les
autorisations environnementales sachant
qu'on n'est pas du tout dans un terrain
naturel on est en pleine industriel donc
je pense que c'est un bien et qu'il faut
que cela se mette en place il y a eu des
débats il y a l'état le préfet a mener
des réunions d'explications notamment
auprès de la population et auprès des
associations principalement écologistes
qui sont inquiète sur le sujet je sais
pas si la levé leur doute mais moi je
suis certaine que ce FSRU est nécessaire
on va terminer en parlant d'une
actualité qui se déroulera au Sénat la
semaine prochaine puisque reviendra le
texte sur la constitutionnalisation de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
en octobre dernier le Sénat est rejeté
ce texte à 172 voix contre 139 et là il
y a une nouvelle formulation de ce texte
que vous examinerez la semaine prochaine
il n'y a plus le mot contraception dans
la nouvelle formulation c'est la loi
garantit l'effectivité l'effectivité et
légale accès aux droits à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse est-ce que du
coup ça change quelque chose
écoutez moi je pense que cette
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG j'ai pas
changé d'avis c'est une fausse bonne
idée on est très attaché je suis très
attaché à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse qui est un droit fondamental
pour les femmes de disposer de leur
corps mais la constitutionnalisation
elle ne va pas renforcer l'effectivité
contrairement à ce que soutiennent les
défenseurs ça va pas renforcer
l'effectivité du droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse ça va pas
augmenter les moyens financiers des
plannings familiaux ça va pas comment
dire lutter contre la désertification
médicale et ça ne protégera pas plus
protégera pas plus l'IVG je pense c'est
symbolique mais inscrire dans la
Constitution l'IVG pour un symbole c'est
même plutôt dangereux parce que ça va
modifier
l'état même de la Constitution surtout
que c'est quand même passez-moi
l'expression mais dans ce domaine là le
bal des hypocrites parce que personne
n'en veut de la constitutionnaliser
constitutionnalisation pardon
sous cette forme là personne ne veut une
proposition de loi qui oblige à
référendum personne ne veut de
l'inscription dans le titre 8 consacré à
l'autorité judiciaire personne ne veut
cette formulation qui vient de
l'Assemblée nationale et qui n'est pas
bonne qui est juridiquement incomplète
et qui créerait des effets forts puisque
elle empêche la conciliation avec la
reconnaissance du droit de l'embryon
donc véritablement le gouvernement n'en
veut pas beaucoup de députés ont voté en
disant toute façon le Sénat retoquera
donc ça sera de la responsabilité du
Sénat cherche auprès de l'opinion
publique à faire pas apporter la
responsabilité sur le scénar dans Sénat
qui passerait comme conservatoire
exactement et donc moi ce que je dis
c'est que c'est au gouvernement de
prendre ses responsabilités c'est au
gouvernement de trouver la solution de
réunir des constitutionnalismes et de
faire des propositions qui s'il veut
aller dans le sens de l'opinion publique
et bien permettra d'inscrire au moins
proprement dans la Constitution ce droit
à l'interruption donc c'est à dire à
travers un projet de loi et donc pas
d'obligation de référendum un projet de
loi et ensuite un projet de loi bien
écrit c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup Agnès canalier d'avoir
été avec nous et pardon on a pas réussi
à se connecter avec la Seine-Maritime
mais vous avez pu parler de l'actualité
de votre département merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous pendant cette
première demi-heure dans 20 minutes on
viendra sur le texte dont on a parlé sur
le texte sur les JO et notamment
l'impact sur les festivals en 2024
sont-ils menacés quel impact pour les
territoires concernés ce sera le débat
du club d'abord on va parler du Parti
socialiste avec notre invité Nicolas
Mayer rossignol